sei stanco del natale
devi ancora fare il regalo di natale al
tuo migliore amico perché anche
quest'anno non sai che cosa cazzo
prenderli ogni [ __ ] anno ti ritrovi
nel negozio di giocattoli per prenderli
qualcosa ma poi ti ricordi che il tuo
amico ha 47 anni
avete mai fatto un regalo con tutto il
cuore che poi si è rivelato una merda ne
hai le palle piene di cercare i regali e
allora ce l'ho io il regalo che fa per
te bellissimo pacco di niente niente
proprio ciò che il tuo amico merita non
ci avete mai pensato prima
la banana e qualcosa niente deve essere
incontaminato amiche mai assaporato il
sapore del nulla e allora niente può
essere meglio di niente niente e per la
persona che sa già tutto
niente è il regalo da scoprire quante
volte vi è capitato di andare da un
vostro amico e dire ho preso un regalo
bomba per natale sarà il regalo
ti giuro davvero sente preso regalo
quando riprendermi niente è infatti
niente
il regalo che fa per te ma e vuote non
c'è niente per la persona che sa tutto
quest'anno spegne anche tu come fa
vigenti 12 euro e cinquanta sua amata
per niente e regala
la felicità di un cazzo di niente questo
prodotto non fa assolutamente niente se
qualcosa succede rimandarlo indietro per
il rimborso se qualche parte di questo
oggetto viene inghiottita per favore
consultare uno psicanalista
ero stanco prima di fare di aver fatto
questo video così ho acceso la
videocamera così mi sono ripreso perché
ero stanco quindi mi sono ripresa avete
capito
pensate queste battute di merda c'è
anche tre milioni di iscritti
quella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo momento sono quali geri prima di
cominciare per chi se lo stesse
chiedendo nel caso vi rispondo già
adesso la risposta è si niente costa
veramente esiste costa veramente 12 euro
e 50 su amazon se non ci credete vi
lascio al link in descrizione ma non vi
sto prendendo per il culo non serve
veramente a un cazzo è solo quella roba
lì sono stati 12 euro 50 più ben spesi
della mia vita c'e neanche andare a
[ __ ] anche ragazzi il video in sé
non era su questo ma questa è una
premessa perché era gazzoli è successa
una cosa bellissima
l'altro giorno un mio iscritto mi ha
postato sulla pagina di facebook questa
foto
questa foto è una foto molto
significativa sul web dove c'è un
manifestante insomma credo sia così che
abbraccia la polizia questo mio fan che
mi ha portato questa foto mi ha detto
che il tifo somigliava esageratamente a
me quindi ragazzi ho deciso di fare un
esperimento per prevedere che cazzo
sarebbe successo una curiosità mi ha
praticamente ho postato questa foto l'ho
presa e l'ho caricata su instagram e ho
messo una frase comica una fase che
avrei scritto io e ho scritto quando ti
prendono tutte e per consolazione
abbracci la polizia visto che sembrava
veramente me ho detto facciamo finta che
sia io vedevo la gente come reagisce
ecco i ragazzi miei arriva il bello vi
faccio vedere qual è stata la reaction
generale di quando caricato questa foto
non me l'aspettavo neanche io
la foto su instagram tra l'altro ha
preso più il più like di b quella di
clementino quindi la polizia
file ai primi commenti sotto la foto
sono stati i seguenti dovuto scorrere
fino all'inizio per trovare i fini
commenti risate generali
bravo fa vj chiamo amore lori tvb
nessuno nessuno che per adesso si è
accorto che non sono io va bene favi
bono poli zone ma no ma cosa ma cosa
abbraccia me invece amore mio
nice ma neanche uno si è accorto che in
realtà voleva non sono io ma è anche uno
ma neanche mezzo voglio essere quel
poliziotto ma do come sei bello
ragazzo che stai abbracciando coccolosa
mente la polizia hai un sacco di
pretendenti visto come è facile trovare
la [ __ ] fa vigenti carica una foto e
trovi un sacco di persone che ti
vogliono limona l'esperimento è stato
bravo cerca di capire quanto ci avrebbe
messo la gente ad accorgersi che data
quello non ero io il problema è stato un
altro è sta roba è diventata talmente
convincente che mio padre stamattina mi
ha mandato un messaggio con scritto
quante volte ti ho detto di non andare
alle manifestazioni mio padre mai
conosciuto mio papà e mio padre come fai
ragazza è tuo figlio perché mio padre è
sempre stato lui ha sempre avuto paura
le manifestazioni che sono pericolose da
certi punti di vista quindi lui è sempre
stato fissato mi ha sempre detto non
esporti nelle manifestazioni con le
violente ovviamente quando ho caricato
la foto mio padre pensavo se data la
manifestazione non debba mai più fare un
funziona sta roba quando andava a scuola
mandavo lui al posto mio porca [ __ ]
nella mia foto di facebook mi hanno
messo tutti quanti il mi piace anche la
mia ex dc presentava lui alla porta che
cazzo cetoli mont avic e mi sento
tradito dentro citato la mierda pensavi
a lui quando lo facevi con me
brava brava brava brava tanto io quando
lo facevo con te pensavo a serena gola e
c'è davvero la sua mi sembra veramente
io problema che non sono io dopo un po
all'inizio nice
ma neanche uno se n'è accorto pian piano
ma poi dopo dopo ore di tempo
veniamo alla fine di commenti ma non
sembra lo re ma non è l'ora non sei tu
non errori che sono entrati tutti
fenomeni prima non di prima neanche uno
anche mio padre poi si vede che c'è
stato un cristiano che se n'è accorto
nei commenti ha scritto guardi non si
vede che non sei tu quello da lui in poi
tutti quanti hanno letto il suo commento
a metà ma non sei tu guarda che buca che
se ne accorgeva qualcuno se non c'era
quello a scriverlo tutti bravi adesso è
che prima non sarà accorto nessuno
adesso tutti bravi sono quindi ragazzi
facciamo un appello e troviamo questo
ragazzo e facciamo di fare dei video al
posto mio
facciamo un cazzo io ho un sacco di
tempo ha un ca ragazzi a parte tutti gli
scherzi il mio intento non era quello di
oltraggiare quello che il significato di
questa immagine perché io comprendo
questa
veramente significativa anzi forse sul
web è una delle immagini più
significative degli ultimi anni e spesso
inserita in un sacco di di album che
fanno magari su facebook sapete quelli
che fanno tipo le immagini più
significative del 2016 per dire no è in
mezzo ci infilano anche questa ogni
tanto è la prima volta che mi fa chi
l'avevo già vista ma è la prima volta
che mi soffermo a vedere quanto il tizio
errata mi somiglia ai ragazzi sono
riusciti a trovare in massa a diverse
centinaia di migliaia di persone
compreso mio padre i ragazzi spero che
vi sia piaciuto concludo che questo
esperimento che cazzo erano non so
neanch'io se vi è piaciuta ragazzi non
si trascina il commento è un mi piace
anche i vari social che come negli hotel
e schizzi si sentì di sky ci vediamo
così un video livello ragazzi